[music]
[singing]
>> All right, what's up everybody man?
We're at Balboa Park. And
uh, you know, we just had an inspiring
philosophy here. JP is here. The Dawah
team don't want to talk to them. So,
I'm going to go ahead and head over
there and see
if they'll talk to me.
You know, I got them to talk to them
last time.
But uh, we'll see. I don't know, man.
Ever since Jacob reminded don't you
know, forgot what a debate was, we
probably won't get a conversation out of
these guys.
Let's try it out.
Hey man.
What's up, fellas?
Is Michelle teaching now?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
Is he Is he What is he on Tik Tok or
something?
What is he What is he on?
I don't want to interrupt him, but I'm
actually curious.
Is he live?
Is he live on So, what is he live on
YouTube or
So, then what is he?
Okay.
Okay, doing a whole sermon. All right.
So, is anybody open to talk today, man?
Open to talk?
Come on, guys.
I got I got Qurans. I got a I got quite
a few.
I got quite a few. Have you Have you
heard of the the different Qira'at?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
Wait, so why wouldn't you want to talk
about the the Cuz that's one of the
biggest misconceptions is like, you
know, people are saying that the
different Qira'at are different Qurans
altogether.
That's That's what That's what I'm
saying.
So, you would you would say that they're
all the same.
I That's That's a I feel like that's a
legitimate question, right? It's nothing
Okay.
Right, that's that's what I get. Like,
they're all They're all Qurans. Are they
all trace back to Muhammad?
But, this is
Yeah.
So, if
No, they
Trust me.
No, trust me. I've I've been on there.
I've been on the Islam Q&A
um
other kind of Islamic websites that
break down certain things. And so, when
when I see like, okay, I go into the
sources, I see that there's different
Qurans that say different things. You
know what I'm saying? And so, we usually
get this like, oh, there's one Quran
that's all the same, right? But, I
actually have different Arabic Qurans
that have different verses or different
wording and stuff like that. So, I I
think that that's important for people
to know.
Yeah. So, like for example, so you have
like a there's what is called the Hafs
reading of the Quran. You heard of those
things?
Yeah. So, with these versus Hafs versus
Warsh or the Duri or Qalun, they would
be differing in wording that would
actually change the context. Like, it's
it's not like something small where it
can just be interchanged. Like, the word
changes the what the verse is saying.
You know what I'm saying? So,
um like for example, there's one if you
look at the Hafs and Warsh, the word
for miskin is is poor person, right? And
masakin is poor people. It's in the
plural. So, to make up for a fast day in
chapter two,
it talks about in order to make up for a
fast day, you got to feed a poor person,
right? To make up for a fast day. That's
in the Hafs.
In the Warsh, it says you have to feed
poor people, masakin.
You know? And so, that that changes the
ruling. If I want to make up for a fast
day, do I just feed one poor person a
day and I'm good? Or do I have to feed
multiple poor people and then I made up
for my fast day, you know? So, like
there's rulings that can be
differed.
Tell them later, man.
Brother, there's like thousands of
people that's going to see this.
You don't care about the people being
I know, we're not we're not debating.
We're We're chilling. We're talking.
This This
Yeah, this
So, you're only here to pass out Qurans.
You're not here to to
But, if But, if Yeah.
Yeah.
This This is This is why This is why
that doesn't sit too well for cuz I
understand if it was If we were coming
on some weird stuff or like
offensive like aggressive like energy,
Yeah, exact right. Exactly. So, I'm I'm
saying I can understand if that was the
case. But, if we come like cuz you set
up a tent, right? You have you know,
Jesus is a Muslim or ask a Muslim
anything. And so, like we come and we we
actually happen to be a you know, a bit
knowledgeable about the religion. So, we
can have discourse about that. And that
would be beneficial to those who can't
engage in these conversations like this,
right? They want to hear these sides.
Let's see this under scrutiny.
Why?
I would I'd talk to you or him. Really,
you You seem You seem cool.
You seem like you know some stuff.
I know. And this is
And this is the And this is the response
we're going to Look, if I came next
Sunday, bro, that y'all He would say the
same thing. He'll say, "Man, we don't
want to talk to you guys. It'll be It'll
It'll be fruitless."
Well, if you say that you If you don't
If you say that you
If you say you don't want to talk to me,
just like I'm going to give you an
answer. If you say you don't want to
talk to me, I see that as a disservice
of what you're here to do. You set up a
tent to talk to people.
Eventually. Yeah, well, once I
Once Once I
Once Once I Once I discern that it's
fruitless, the interaction, but
Not Not Not Not Not just No, I
don't want you to be destroyed, bro.
I care about your soul, bro.
I I love you and I want you to be saved,
man.
No, I'm I'm supposed I'm supposed to
give you the gospel anyway.
What But, but on on whose on whose end,
though?
On whose end?
Your Quran doesn't say that.
Your Quran says that your The Quran says
that your God and my God are one.
Wait Wait Wait Wait Hey, right?
Okay,
go and fight them. So, they could
convert. What do they have to do?
And so on and so forth.
The first The first The first verse
doesn't have anything to do with
to the people of the book.
Why not?
You You can literally clear up a
misconception right now, bro. That
doesn't make any sense. Like, if you If
If anybody comes up to a Christian to
say, "You'll never have him say, 'Oh,
no, we don't want to talk to you.'" And
because you're knowledgeable and stuff
like that. Like, that is like that's
that's off.
I do this for education. I don't I don't
do this for clips.
You seen my videos, right?
Okay. And it's educational.
So, why why is not Why is now not the
time? That's what I'm hearing.
That's
It's not the one time. That's the point.
When when we come over here Look, even
the last time I was here, Michelle said,
"No, we don't we don't want to talk to
you." Why? Why don't you guys want to
talk to knowledgeable people?
You can say You You can say that.
If you say I was cooked by Sheikh
Uthman, why didn't he step up to debate
me when he challenged me to debate?
Yeah, look at look at his face.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
It's just Okay, be honest about it. I I
got Look, I can I I hear you.
I hear you.
But, it's not It's not a not right now.
It's not a right now It's not a right
now right now. You're not being honest.
You're not being honest. You're not
being honest. Okay, let me tell you how.
When you say respectfully, when you say
respectfully, that means that you have
an honest intention. You're You're just
denying the conversation. Not right now.
But that's not your intention. You don't
want If I bet you if one of these random
people came up to talk to you guys and
ask you about Islam, you guys will stand
up with an instant and talk about Islam
and ask answer their questions. But
because you know that I know Islam and
he knows Islam, you won't talk to us.
>> the case. So then be Be honest about it
at least.
>> 2 weeks ago we had um
people who believed I think they're
Yahwists is what they call them and I
might be butchering that. So they're
they're essentially like I don't want to
say Israelites, but they believe in uh
that Yeshua and everything like that.
And we had a conversation with them for
about 2 hours. Mishak spoke to them. Uh
He spoke to them.
He spoke Actually, no, he wasn't there.
So I was also speaking to them. They had
like the You know the horns that they
the the that they carry They they had
those carrying them on them. So it was a
very like fruitful conversation. They're
very respectful.
But eventually it came to a point where
we were like, "Hey man,
we're good. Like we're we're Yeah.
>> This is going to take too long."
So it's just like
You didn't even give us that chance.
But we know We didn't know who they
were. Exactly.
>> know who they were. That's what I'm
saying. They were
They were also very knowledgeable on
Islam. So it's not a it's not a But you
didn't know that. If you knew they were
knowledgeable, you would not have talked
to them in the first place. We We love
speaking to Christians who know their
stuff because it's I mean it's just
It's better, right? It's better. Yeah.
>> So it's the same way when you guys talk
to us, you guys want us to know a little
bit about the gospel.
>> Yes.
Why wouldn't we know about the gospel,
you know? Like it's We also believe in
parts of the gospel as well. It's just
It It's just
a matter of respect. Like We don't want
to talk right now.
>> See, that's not what it You're not being
real. So you almost had me. I was right
I was I was right there with you. You
want to make me feel bad and you want to
pull my heartstrings to say, "Oh, well,
they're going to run away because
>> No, no, no. You You got your mind made
up. You know, you you said what you
said. That's fine. I just I'm just I
just want to let it be known. We'll try
to answer them, but if they're but if
they're trying to debate like this, but
we we don't like to go on for hours and
stuff.
>> I I I I get you. But
all I'm all I'm saying
All I'm All I'm saying, brother, all I'm
saying is that with you how you're open
and you're and like you know this. If
someone were to come up here and they
were to come up here
and they were to come up here and ask
you come ask you questions about Islam
or even Christianity, you would indulge,
right?
Me, even though you you know who I am,
if I ask questions about Islam because I
don't believe in it and I have
criticisms, you are not going to engage
me because you know that I know about
Islam. You know that about me already.
You know that I have a platform. You're
not going to talk to me. Be just be
honest about that.
>> If you If you know about Islam, it's one
thing. Yes.
Muslims, we always have conversations
with the Christians about everything.
Not knowledgeable ones.
But there are knowledgeable people who
speak to each other to each other about
about the religions with each other.
What about here at this on this
platform?
>> Because It's one message.
>> We feel that it's not a Like I said,
it's not a fruitful conversation. It's
like
It's like talking to a brick wall. You
have no idea. You never spoke to me.
Yeah, and and
No, no, no.
Would you talk to him? Would you talk to
me? Because you're associated to him.
You are you are who
your friends with. And by the way, it's
not going to make me feel bad.
Yeah, I know. I know. I know. I
What's your name, bro? Alex. Alex.
Avery.
I'll let you go, man. I just What's up?
What's up, Wyatt?
Silver. You can call me Silver. That's
my real name.
So but to be clear, if somebody came up,
you didn't know,
would you
Would Would you Would you talk to
somebody if they said, "Hey man, I
disagree with Islam and here's why." If
they were If you didn't know them and
they just came up to the table, would
you talk to them?
Cuz I don't know them. Probably, yeah.
But you guys are here. That's an honest
answer. That's an honest answer.
My name is Avery, man.
You what? My name is Avery. I know. You
just Yeah, yeah. So
You guys have an intention. You guys are
very being very deliberate. It's great.
It's just Today's not that day.
If you come If you come over here again,
So if I So if I come here next week,
will you be here?
I might be, yeah. If my schedule is open
up. Are Are you open to talking?
Dude,
we're always here on Sundays. I'm
talking about you specifically. Are you
open to talking?
Because like like I said, it's a it's a
brick wall.
>> You don't know that. But you would If
you want to talk to someone like I'm not
even that knowledgeable about like Islam
and Christianity. It's not about that.
It's It's It's about sharing It's about
sharing beliefs and and ideas.
>> that's what I'm saying. I I think it's I
think it's more fruitful I think it's
more fruitful What about the What about
the audience? It's more fruitful for the
audience to have a more organized
conversation with someone who's more
knowledgeable than I am.
Wow. So then you guys shouldn't be here.
Y'all should not be here.
You don't have to be as a leader. If
you're not knowledgeable enough to talk
about Islam, you shouldn't
Then how are Then how are you learning
if you're not engaging?
He's also very He's pretty
knowledgeable, too.
Yeah, I'm just Yeah, I'm just I'm just
saying for a lot of the conversations
that I've had, they've been
very productive. I'm a respectful guy. I
don't cuss at you guys or you know,
nothing like that. We wouldn't do that.
We wouldn't do that. I I trust that you
wouldn't do that. You know, we have good
conversations and I think that
because of we have a large audience,
it's it it helps so many people have
these conversations and so
um
it it's it is a disservice to not engage
when you guys put up a tent like this
and somebody knowledgeable comes around.
So
But okay.
All right. So
I'm not the one holding the booth. I'm
not the holder. I come in here. I help
with the side things. I hand out extra
things. I also speak Spanish. So like if
someone needs to kind of like ask a
basic question about Islam, I say it in
Spanish and I have one of the brothers
with me. It's kind of about this. I'm
here just
I'm here I'm I'm I'm just I'm in the
background. I'm a background guy.
But why would you want to engage with
people
Why are you going to do that if you're
not going to I wasn't going to
originally engage at all.
I'm just saying that I'm going to have a
discussion with people that doesn't know
a lot
about whether Islam or even
Christianity. But you wouldn't want to
I'm But like I said, yes. Why am I
holding the booth? I'm not the holder.
I I hear I'm here. I set up the booth. I
help them move up things. I sit in the
back. I enjoy the weather.
I sit with the brothers and I and I
listen.
If some If
If somebody had
If If somebody asked you why you
personally believe Islam is true, you
would give them reasons for that, right?
And you would hope that even those
reasons would convince them or even open
their minds to to something new, right?
That they have probably haven't accepted
or thought about before. And vice versa
with Christianity in a Christian
conversation. Or even your that belief
that you give could be under scrutiny
and you can show that person that even
under scrutiny
these stand, right? There's because it's
the truth.
So
That's That's the point of the debate,
the discussion, the engagement. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's that's perfectly fine.
Y'all Y'all should stop doing this, bro.
What would you guys consider English
Bibles to be real Bibles? I mean, but
that's a different story because It's a
different religion.
revealed in this language. And then
these words are considered to be an
uncreated and eternal words of Allah.
On the front obviously it says the real
Quran.
What is it going to say? Translation
It's trans trans But this is And it says
the author. It says the publications
inside so that you can find the you
know, who wrote it, how did they write
it, how did they come up with the
translation cuz it's a Semitic language.
Arabic is a Semitic language. No, I I
get it, but do you It's It's like the
Bible, you know. It's in Aramaic, Greek,
and What was that? Do you consider it to
be a real Quran?
It's a What do you mean a real Quran?
Like in What's your intention with it?
Because I'm not going to play
>> No, it's not. I'm just asking questions.
That's it. Okay, yeah. So when you give
them this Quran and you believe that the
Quran was revealed in Arabic and these
words are considered to be an uncreated
and eternal,
Okay, so I'm going to give all you guys
a Bible in
>> Because the actual Quran is actually in
Arabic and it should be read in Arabic.
This is also a Quran. It's in Spanish.
So So it seems like you have a different
view, but like usually Muslims will tell
us that they that only the the the
Quran, the actual Quran is in is in
Arabic and the English Qurans that are
passed out are not actual Qurans. I
think that's I think that's just
Honestly, maybe more of like a a lack of
explanation. It's more like a lack of
explanation. It's like that that the
real Quran is only in Arabic.
So it's like I think it's just But I
think So the English Qurans are not like
the English translations.
So they're not Like as he was saying,
these are not real Qurans.
So why Why are you giving a fake Quran
for?
How is it a fake Quran? It is, brother.
So then what about the Bibles that are
in English? Are you guys having them all
in Arabic? Because the Bible doesn't
mention that the Bible needs to be
revealed in these particular languages.
Just like how the Quran makes a claim.
Because the Quran is making a claim that
it's revealed in Arabic and it needs to
be read in Arabic
for a clear guidance. And it says that
it's considered to be an uncreated and
eternal.
Twist of words. It's It's just a
different language.
You want to make it easier to understand
for other people, so you go from the
Arabic to the original of the full
meaning. Do you speak Arabic? I do.
So, you know that Arabic
>> Yeah, yeah, so you know Arabic is a lot
more deeper meaning than like English.
English is a Germanic language, it's a
very blunt language. So, in in Espanol,
we also have like a certain translation.
It's not going to be the same perfect
meaning, just the way that Jesus, peace
be upon him, he spoke Aramaic, right?
Sure, he He spoke Well, I mean, how do
you know that he spoke Aramaic?
That's what That's what scholars have
said, you Which which scholars? And
where do they get their I don't know. I
don't know. I don't know.
I mean, he made a good claim.
Once again,
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Guys, So, you were engaging in good
dialogue. No, but but
But, you know what had happened? He
started to pull that out again. You guys
want He's been recording this whole
time.
Come on, man. He's been recording this
whole time, bro.
This has nothing to do with it, bro.
Alex, you're too good for this, bro.
He is. He is too good for this. He's not
supposed to be You're too good for this,
Alex.
You're You're You're too good for this,
Alex, honestly.
Cuz you're you're Look at you. You're
No, he's right. But, you're you're ready
to have a conversation You're ready to
engage.
Yes, you do, bro. I don't. You can't
help it. As soon as you guys were over
here, I was like,
>> [laughter]
>> You were like, "I'm ready to have a
conversation."
>> No, it's a brick wall, uh so You guys
have a great day.
Listen, listen, Silver. You guys have a
great day.
May we be well. Yeah, I guess. I mean,
all right. No problem, brother. It was
nice meeting you guys. Nice meeting you
guys.
What happened over there? Oh, you know,
they wouldn't talk.
Running as usual, you know. You know the
usual.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
So, you you guys see how it is, man.
They set up a tent.
Set up a big tent. It literally says,
"Ask a Muslim anything." That's what it
says. Christians come up.
You talk about Jesus, you talk about
Moses, you talk about our biblical
figures, and you don't want to talk. You
accuse it of Oh, well, you know, it's
like talking to a brick wall, but then
admitted that you will talk to someone
that you don't know. You know who we
are. You're going to talk to somebody
that you don't know. We don't know if
they have knowledge or not.
That's So, there it is. They will do not
want to talk to people of knowledge. If
they know you have knowledge, they won't
talk to you. Wow. It's a cult, man.
Is God
>> [music]
>> Is God
Is God
>> [music]
[singing]